hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen I have
large giant freckles that are extremely
fake on in honor of the weird earthling
elf princess woman troll in a disguise
character in the beginning of the film
like literal globs of brown make up your
face why I'm them if you're not gonna
attempt it all to make them look good
what huh I had heard before that this is
like the holy grail of bad movies that
are fun it's very similar to the room
thank you for contributing Ike oh my god
[Music]
what who did this who made this choice
how who what where when why what I
couldn't even write down everything I
wanted to write down because there were
so many lines I wanted to quote and so
many things that I wanted to bring up
I'm sure it's all been done before I've
been told that a lot of people review
this this is like the thing that you
talk about as a movie reviewer but I'm
not a movie reviewer I'm just tipsy girl
on a couch it opens on a scene with
Joshua our hero of the story and his
grandfather reading to him very nice
then you get really close up mouth shots
of the grandpa reading of the book not
not as nice
so he's reading this story about goblins
and everything is a goblin in this hour
trolls and goblins the same thing I
seriously don't know but they're all
called goblins in this movie and it's
called troll too so maybe it's like
troll - attack of the goblins I don't
know
I love
yes Joshua's sister lifts weights like a
badass yes then the next note is oh my
god she is the worst actor I've ever
seen ever ever it will be wonderful
Elliot my father hates you I'll tell my
father you're coming on vacation with us
can you do it I can't even do the leg
level of shit acting that she is
Eliot is her boyfriend her family
doesn't like and I know it was a
different time but I will never be
comfortable with homophobic statements
that were said in 80s movies all the
time but also kicking a guy in the nuts
doesn't make him a homo everyone knows
that right except for Elliot so Elliot's
like yeah I'll show up in the morning
I'll go on vacation with you and then he
doesn't show up in the morning and he
doesn't go on vacation and the daughter
and the dad are fighting and they're so
bad and the mom is like stop fighting
before my vacation
Joshua seeing Josh was like I don't want
to sing mom I don't want to
she's like singing that song I like you
like what song is it gonna be and it's
row row row your boat it's got the
perfect like pop sound your heartstrings
row row row your boat gently just there
you go on vacation and it's like a
vacation swap situation like they stay
in someone else's home and then somebody
else stays in their home they show up to
the house and the family who are
obviously trolls have left out this food
and the grandpa appears to Joshua and
it's like don't eat that food don't let
them eat that food and then he freezes
the family and Josh was supposed to go
take care of the food situation he's
like what do I do
[Laughter]
there's so many other options he could
have he could make he could have done
anything else anything and he chose to
piata and I respect that Joshua I
respect it I won't allow you to pee on
hospitality I boot then you meet the
actual worst actress I've ever seen this
is my house my ancestors
from Stonehenge I am a 28 year old
actress who just has terrible makeup on
then you get the great the greatest line
in the film which is oh my god you can't
even like really explain this film so
I'm trying to go in order here but I
mean if you haven't seen it you just
gotta see it cuz it's so much fun the
next scene is is the sister and she's
like dancing in the mirror she does the
eyeglasses like while dancing that's not
a move is it when she sees her grandpa
so Joshua goes into a room later and
it's a cramp oh crap are you here the
grand was like yeah what happened
Joshy was like you went to the wrong
room grandpa so this it goes like well I
still have to figure out the layout of
this place Joshua it's stupid then you
see Arnold he's a tree now why oh I
guess it's a cool idea to make him into
a tree even though it makes no sense
with the story or unless I missed it but
like it doesn't make sense in the story
twice he's a tree it's supposed to look
super sweet but like all the vines that
they use our plastic vines that you get
the dollar store why are you using
plastic vines when you're gonna go super
close in on it it looks stupid then out
of nowhere the sister punches her
boyfriend Elliot's straight in the face
because he has friends so that's cool
countess what is her name
Creedence Creedence it's like I need all
of my powers give me all of my old
powers and her hand grows back and then
it's revealed that she's young
it's like it gave her life back or
something it's like we all knew she's
just a terrible make up on we knew I've
never seen someone seduced with Korn
before
and I still haven't troll to the most
Awkward and long sex scene with corn
that you'll ever see
thumbs up being a lot so the trolls the
goblins they're all trying to get the
family at this point and they hold a
seance for grandmas death to come back
you know as families do Joshua just
kills out grandpa Sabbath come
it's not funny outta my way so Joshua
pretty much destroys all of the goblins
by eating a bologna sandwich and they
start yelling think of the fast think of
the cholesterol you could have written
anything better than that you couldn't
have written okay okay okay Joshua
defeats the goblins they go home and the
goblins aren't defeated somehow somehow
they're still around and they eat they
eat Joshua's mom and I wrote down listen
wrap this up but we don't care but then
that's the end they just end it on his
mother being eaten by God but the
perfect ending to a perfect film
prediction you'll be saying oh my god
for months afterward I say oh my God
Allah already so I'll just add a couple
extra good odds to it oh there's a lot
of people who are saying oh my god
eating popcorn will never feel the same
way
it does taste a bit too green I predict
you'll be disgusted that the kid chose
to pee on the food instead of just
tossing it in the garbage
yes loved it I'll predict you'll laugh
at the they're eating her and then
they're gonna eat me seem yes loved it
I predict a cameo from Mike the cat got
it I predict you'll do a million hair
what did you think
never again will you allow someone to
piss on hospitality I bow from this
moment on you will feel compelled to eat
an ear of corn with your favorite
gentleman caller
Mike again looking at you something is
so creepy about the mother character can
never tell if it's just her or the
direction I get that feeling about all
the characters I think the mother the
creepy part about her is that her eyes
never feel like they're focused on
anything it's like a soft gaze in in
very extreme moments which is like
yelling Joshua to save his life like
maybe pick a spot to look at it you will
love credence objectively the best
character in the movie she was my
favorite and my least favorite character
all in one next Friday is December 1st
and I think I might start it off with
the Star Wars Christmas special
maybe it's pretty much the only Star
Wars content I haven't seen though on my
personal channel I do have a series
called Tamra had scene where I explained
pop Star Wars to everyone in a very
accurate manner
super super accurate
very real very serious thank you so so
much for watching I'll see you all next
week with the start of December can't
wait oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
you